[Music]
star wars battlefront - underperformed
and was a learning opportunity for EA
according to CFO Blake Jorgensen in what
is probably the kindest criticism I
think the games received so far I'm just
MacDonald and this is a GameSpot news
update designed to feed the
schadenfreude of those of you who like
seeing EA stumble the publisher
confirmed to the Wall Street Journal
that battlefront 2 shipped 9 million
copies during its launch quota
for comparison's sake 2015's battlefront
reboot shipped 13 million copies during
its launch quarter EA had projected it
would shift 10 million units for
battlefront - so it ultimately fell 1
million short of expectations Jorgenson
added the battlefront 2 will reintroduce
microtransactions quote in the next few
months after their absence following the
controversy over how EA originally
handled them EA CEO Andrew Wilson
explained going forward we believe that
live services that include optional
digital monetization when done right
provide a very important element of
choice that can extend and enhance the
experience in our games we're committed
to continually working with our players
to deliver the right experience in each
of our games and life services EA
stressed that 9 million shipped units is
still a massive achievement and over
their respective first 3 months
battlefront 2 players logged twice as
much play time as the 2015 battlefront
game players overall a a reported 1.16
billion in revenue and a 186 million
dollar loss during the final quarter of
last year though the company did inker a
176 million tax expense related to the
new tax cuts and Jobs Act for more on EA
big numbers and sales figures ahead to
our stories on GameSpot
you